we got some new merch made but it's only
exclusive for our petrie honors
so if you go on our patreon we got some
new tiers we got the coffee mug tear
and the hoodie tier and if you're
defibrillator you get
both so make sure you go to patreon
check that out and thank you guys so
much for supporting and enjoy the video
[Music]
you know how over time as civil
civilizations i can't say that word
civilizations did i say right
as civilizations advance we end up
leaving our history behind
um and it's kind of sad right now am i
the only one that i'm like
do you want to repeat it again oh do you
know how
civilizations advance yes and then we
end up leaving our history behind
absolutely and and then that's kind of
sad what's the sound superstar
we just build like new [ __ ] on top of it
i'm kind of okay with us leaving world
war ii behind in the depression and
i'm talking about like structural
structural
things oh like like the pyramids like
ancient aliens
ah yeah yeah yeah we have a toilet on
top of old native american burial
grounds
yeah i like that but yeah like who knows
what's under
this building you know like what have we
covered up japanese internment camp
yep it's true a lot of them still live
in my neighborhood
culver city oh that's true you're by
little osaka
i am great ramen over there on saturday
oh yeah yeah oh
yeah well uh there's this this grocery
store the supermarket
called little have you guys heard of it
and and it's in dublin but they have
like a chain
all over the place anyway so they are a
supermarket and they recently opened up
a store where they restored an
archaeological site
underneath this supermarket to allow its
shoppers to see it and actually
appreciate it so you're just pushing
your shopping cart and everyone's
crashing because you're just looking
underground yeah it's like glass
you're saying dublin ireland yes dublin
ireland yeah well they have cool [ __ ] we
wouldn't have no
we don't have old [ __ ] like we built a
grocery store on top of a piggly wiggly
that's right yeah i guess when i was
saying we like as like the world
yeah yeah i was in jordan and um
there was my cousins were like uh yeah
you wanna go see something
cool like we're gonna go kind of just go
up in the mountains and like go smoke
hookah i was like cool
they drive us up um and there's no like
guards toll booths there's just you
drive up this mountain
and then when we get to the top ancient
ancient ruins like we're talking 2 000
years old
and where you can still see like the
foundation of where the rooms were
wow wow like that should be in the
[ __ ]
can i i mean it was like your fragments
or old pots
yeah but they should be in the museum
kind of stuff right but it's just
chilling they're like just pulled out
two fold out chairs and we sat down and
like
you know yeah smoked hookah out in this
like what that's tight
what always survives the old pots the
old spoons
why didn't they just make everything out
of that [ __ ]
is this a bit no dude it's a [ __ ]
baby dishware yeah all that little
survives because women know how to take
care of stuff
that's what it is it's true we should
make everything out of clay again
that's what i'm saying play cars
uh cars yeah clay street shops
imagine if everyone had clay cars and
then you get into a crash
that should just break apart nobody's
hurt it'd be a much more pleasant sound
you want to go back to the flintstones
play cards are there
still rubber tires just of course they
are bart oh
what kind of [ __ ] question is that of
course they're rubber
clay cars you rubber yes no he wants
everything clay not rubber even though
would probably reflect the time and it
would be either
wood or stone spinners
[Laughter]
glass too doesn't it last a long time
like the last a long time
yeah i don't know but anyway i'm going
to show you guys a video of this
dublin supermarket they're doing too
much
it's cool but they're doing too much i
feel like i'm going to go you could see
underground
yep what's under there oh it's like
demolition man
from toys to tools to trumpets oh it's
just that section
okay well there's like other parts of
this
door as well wow
[Music]
okay they're faking all these movements
bro
for dublin we don't know if it's
anything quite like this in the city
i'm sure it functions as many things as
a house
as an extra space for the family it's a
domestic
structure so we have to imagine there
would have been a suburb here
um of our borough north stubborners who
are effectively the ancestors of the
vikings that's right uh the two main
archaeological features
these are the fakest irish accents so
funny yeah
i love it we then have a lot of
information
uh displays around the store that helps
people
[Music]
like having history with modern times my
my question is though like all right
did you guys see anything because i just
saw dirt yeah
it was like rock piles i just saw
[ __ ] dirt i didn't see anything
like cool yeah but if you're going to
have a grocery store museum
i think that lives up to it it's cool
yeah you're not wrong
it would just be tough to be an
archaeologist have this be your like
life's work and then also be asked where
the butter is
you know like right that's what i mean i
work under the
[Laughter]
i do this 1 000 times a day i wanted to
see like a horned helmet
in a house oh that'd be tight you know
what i mean like a hammer
post viking era oh it's post i thought
there was one
little [ __ ] yeah that's when they
stopped stabbing people huh
they just start fighting people yeah
they're saying it's a
11th century home that was discovered
have you guys been to the basement level
of the loof
in paris huh the basement level of yeah
the castle
ruins right yeah that's pretty cool they
built the museum on top of that oh
really i didn't know that there's castle
ruins down there yeah when you on the
way out
yeah you can go we have a good fast
memory they'll show you oh i love that
place
yeah the the i love museums man i could
be in there for hours did you go to the
napoleon one
that one was one of my favorite i gotta
go back
and do it again the military museum that
was tight yeah man they were so small
yeah it's like children's in in a
[ __ ]
army outfit they're like literally like
extra small like what would be
our size of an extra small or small team
that was their uniform
like they're even the average size of
dudes back then like five three or
something look like so yeah like five
three 100 pounds dude imagine how many
of those dudes you could have [ __ ] up
you could have taken so they would bring
you out as like you know in the
beginning of that movie troy where brad
pitt comes out and he has to fight the
biggest dude
you would have been the big guy what
about him if that was historically
correct
that giant was probably like five eight
yeah and everyone else was
like three five there was a knights suit
um on a on a massive horse and he looked
like over six feet though
so there were tall people i'm assuming
like it had to happen right
wasn't everything smaller though weren't
the horses smaller but everything was
smaller they were all pony
sized i think there's some weird [ __ ]
like a [ __ ] three-person pistol
like you like the person the trigger was
over here and then the barrel like
a guy holding it over his shoulder and
another guy holding the end of it
it was just one shot what it's like the
joker gun in batman 1989
yeah yeah were the flag cops yeah but
it's like a
10 foot [ __ ] pistol but it took three
people to operate it crazy man wow it's
weird
dude i'd love to [ __ ] up some old
medieval
feel like a warrior huh it's like a
video game like they're like the easy
kill
and they're so weak and they're always
like they they were malnourished back
then too they only ate [ __ ] bread
i know dude there was a there was a
reddit like
story idea that got optioned for a movie
and it was where
a guy goes back in time and he has a i
think he has a machine gun
and he's just [ __ ] up every army wow
yeah it's pretty cool idea for movies
i'll be funny
until he runs out of bullets that's the
butterfly effect of that
i i don't know i just i just saw the
pitch yeah
and i got option which is cool but that
could mean it'll never happen too
you never know that is true like held on
to the idea they bought the rights and
they're like yeah maybe we'll make it
they realize it's like a short film 15
minutes and we don't really know what to
do after he runs out of bullets
yeah it's kind of like a kung fury
situation
it wears off after a while yeah but
i don't know i thought it was pretty
interesting how they preserved history
well like i said it was in demolition
man in that movie one of my favorite
stallone movies
um they their museum is like that where
it's glass
and then below it is like old la you
know where they're
and then above it yeah it's like and you
know they they
break it and then they go down and it's
like uh old cars you know and it was uh
drama yeah yeah well future like
futurama had this underground city right
here talking about that was preserved
inner earth we can get into some inner
earth talk
um some people believe the earth is more
of a honeycomb as opposed to
some people journey to the center of the
earth some people believe that the moon
is hollow as well
absolutely and it's a space station for
aids well they drop the uh
the um the the moon uh
lunar module you can finish your
sentence for you right now but you won't
um they dropped it as a science
experiment as the uh as buzz and kneel
and
the other one as they were taking off
they dropped the
the useless part of the module to see
what would happen
and it rang like a bell for hours what
do you think of that [ __ ]
what is this for real the moon did or
that piece of metal they had a
seismograph
yeah the metal did yeah it was a metal
the metal hit it
yeah but then it was it it rang
so long that it would had to have been
it indicated that it was a
could have been hot let me ask you this
i also believe there is
not what if it was made out of a gong
does that mean true
does that mean the earth is hollow or
perhaps there was some instrumentation
failure i think it's a
you think the earth is hollow the more
interesting option is the right one
exactly
but what about the volcanoes well they
just announced that they saw
they they saw proof of water on the moon
and [ __ ] yeah i can't participate in
this because my son is only
like he's just learned that there's only
eight planets so
i can't go past that you know how
obsessed i am with space i do know hobbs
but i can't participate because that's
all i know well they should teach
the fact that uh the germans had a
breakaway civilization and went to the
moon and had a base and then
subsequently mars i don't believe you
but is that true where does all the dark
money go
it goes into top secret black trillions
of dollars that just evaporated it was
missing
you know right before 9 11 happened
right before 9 11 happened
the uh pentagon lost three trillion
dollars
and then they were getting um castled
for it and then 9 11 happened
how why did that happen huh to distract
me
why are you saying that the money went
to mars then it's the
program the moon-based tiff no because
then he said
you they went from the moon to mars
that's what he just said well the
germans did the germans the nazi germans
they went to antarctica first then they
went to the moon they had
perfected uh spacecrafts much like what
we would call ufos today they actually
they figured we first uh engineered that
technology from um
crash disks went to antarctica and then
we sent a fleet to antarctica they beat
our ass we went back
germans went to the moon and then mars
and
still are up there today and then we did
operation paperclip and then we took
we brought nazis we brought nazi
scientists over and then they helped
us
and our whole space program is founded
by occultists jack parsons
look it up it's very interesting not too
far from where we record this podcast
jpl i can't look it up because then i
get all [ __ ] up and i'm like why am i
even here
it's all fake i haven't been right since
i looked at the article years ago
oh [ __ ] just before 9 11 too also
the airlines got sold after after i read
this stuff i just open up pornhub and
jack off
nice that's a way to cope
[Music]
you